terraform modules the new release of ibm
cloud pack for integration and an
updated cloud functions dashboard all on
this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud jumping right into things today
ibm cloud schematics is excited to
announce the general availability of
reusable terraform modules to rapidly
build your ibm cloud infrastructure
what are terraform modules you ask their
logical groupings of terraform
configuration files that are developed
based on common infrastructure code
patterns best practices and reference
architectures
there are a bunch of great benefits to
using these terraform modules on ibm
cloud they accelerate the development of
terraform infrastructure code they lower
the skill barrier required to develop
the code and by using these modules
you're adopting up-to-date industry best
practices and code patterns that are
codified by our automation subject
matter experts
we already have a bunch of ibm terraform
modules published to the terraform
registry and more are being added so
click the link in the description of
this video to get started
next up i want to shine a light on the
latest release of the ibm cloud pack for
integration
the new features of this release mean
that there are now five major ways that
cloud pack for integration's ai powered
automation improves your outcomes
first is natural language integration
which allows you to describe your
desired integration flow simply by using
natural language
second is the transformation generator
which lets you define the format of
source and target data and automatically
generates the complex mapping
transformation
third is ai for api testing which
automatically observes the api traffic
in a production environment identifies
where it lacks test coverage and builds
tests with no human input
fourth is mapping assist which
automatically maps a source to a target
using semantic understanding
and fifth is cloud native high
availability for ibm mq this
automatically replicates message data
between a set of mq instances deployed
into the cloud
to learn more about the exciting new
features of this release hit the link
below
to finish things up this week let's take
a look at the all new activations
dashboard for ibm cloud functions
among the many improvements to the ui
and the ux the new dashboard
restructures the filtering options sorts
the data in every graph in a
chronological and synced up order
improves warning and error messages adds
a better line break to display logs in
the preview accordion and adds a fully
functional dark mode
to start experimenting with the all new
activations dashboard for ibm cloud
functions check out the link i've got
below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud now
you